and the eighties remix keep on coming
they don't stop this is Brynn McCormack
we are so happy to have you with us
Footloose is a remake of the Kevin Bacon
film The Musical and you know it's a
much beloved musical more by people not
so much by critics I looked it up and
actually the newer one has a higher
Rotten Tomatoes rating than the older
one which is kind of interesting
stars Kenny Wormald and Julianne oh I
can just see it now Chris is actually
Julianne how you're incorrect there I'm
going to type this statement and I can
just see this now I'm going to comment
exactly what Chris just said so I can be
cool and they can thumbs it up it's a
really silly premise it's about a town
where dancing and public has become
outlawed and playing your music really
loud or also against the law and because
of some kids who were killed in a car
crash a few years back coming back from
a dance and so they decided to pass this
law and so it's like these kids are
fighting back against the lawn they're
you know we have a right to dance and
everything in yellow that's that's fun
it's a fun idea I think you're gonna
love no money no money are you kidding
me I actually had a lot of fun with this
movie and it's because the movie was
aware of what it is you know it knows
it's just a fun dance movie when you got
a movie like this all you need is a few
things you need super high energy that's
very important obviously good dancing
and good music and actors who are
invested in what they have and a
director who treats it with respect and
we have that here we have all of those
things here and I really like that about
this movie they didn't just you know
we're gonna make a remake and make it a
cash card they treated the source
material with respect they treated the
fans with respect I appreciate that
where people do have just hang out yeah
another sense I don't want you to see
that boy again why because I've heard
he's trouble now this lead guy Kenny
Wormald he's actually pretty good in the
movie I thought that he had a lot of
charisma and that he was really I liked
him a lot in the movie like this
character and I like the way he
portrayed his character he remind me a
lot of John from the flick pic channel I
don't know man I like blu-rays I have
very low self-esteem this movie was kind
of like my Uncle Bob you know he was
kind of dumb but you're respected him
for what he was you know
this movie was a lot of fun you know
they had good dancing it had actors who
seemed like they they they were aware of
what they were in and that's that's
really needed like there are certain
movies that you know or like really
silly and dumb but the filmmakers like
actually trying to make a really good
movie with it which is I guess admirable
but you need to be aware of what you are
in and what you are making in and these
all the people involved this movie are
aware of what it is it's a remake of an
80s film and they're treating it with
respect and they know when they're aware
of the fact that it's a silly plot but
they're just like relishing it you know
there were a few things that know me
about the movie and really just the idea
of the pull the whole plot is very silly
and and we know that going in we know
what the plot is and so you just have to
deal with that basically for the first
half of the movie I really didn't like
the female lead of the movie I
understand that your comic supposed to
actually you're supposed to see problems
with her you're supposed to see that you
need to change but I think that it was a
little hard for me at first I was like
oh man I really don't like this girl at
all as her character matured it seemed
like her performance matured as well I
also like that as quite in the film a
lot of people are hating on it because
they want to because it's popular to
hate on something that's everyone else
is hating on it's so easy to jump on a
crowd and be like yes this movies dumb
it's an 80s remake it's useless why
would they do it's not going to be as
good as the original and blah blah blah
and it's easy to hate on a movie like
that I really like to step up three as
well and and that was a movie the lot
that people it's easy to hate on movies
like that but that had the best dancing
still that I've ever seen in a movie and
as soon as I got home from Footloose I
literally got my iPod put it in and I
danced in my room for like like a half
an hour it's just it's one of those
movies that makes you feel that way if
you like to dance like me it's seriously
it's not a bad movie it's a lot of fun
I'm gonna give the loose a beat
my name is run
and I want to move on behalf of most of
the senior class of Beaumont high that
the law against public dancing within
the town limits of Beaumont be abolished
if you liked my review you can subscribe
to my channel and get stuck my eyes